moi je fais partie des français qui sont
très perplexe on pas dit réticents à la
vaccination
[Musique]
c'est une question qu'on me pose souvent
un quantum contacts sur les réseaux
sociaux d'abord j'ai envie de remercier
celles et ceux qui la pose parce que ça
veut dire qu'ils me témoignent une
véritable confiance j'ai déjà fait de la
politique donc je sais ce que c'est la
politique j'ai été parlementaire
européen députés j'ai été conseiller
d'herminis mise de l'intérieur donc je
connais ce milieu là pour aller dans une
candidature comme la présidentielle il
faut un programme donc une équipe
et puis il faut beaucoup de moyens
financiers le programme je me sens
incapable d'élaborer un programme parce
que je me sens bien à notre pays et j'ai
quand même un peu d'expérience une
équipe c'est pas le plus difficile à
constituer moyens financiers c'est plus
compliqué on sait pas de quoi sera fait
demain donc je ferme aucune porte et en
même temps je tire pas de plan sur la
comète
je laisse faire le le temps et puis
chacun son destin quoi
[Musique]
il ya une chose qui est certaine c'est
que il ya peu de présidents de la
république
curieux encaissé autant de crise une
crise d'abord sociale avec les gilet
jaune et on peut comprendre
effectivement ce mouvement une crise
sécuritaire avec le terrorisme qui
frappe notre pays
et là on a été tous touché au coeur et
puis il ya eu la crise sanitaire de
lakovic qui a touché la planète
donc c'est vrai qu'il ya peu de
président la république conduit en
question une triple crise donc en trois
ans trois ans de mandat
donc c'est vrai que manuel macron je
dirai pas qui est un peu le chat noir
mais en tout cas c'est compliqué pour
lui alors on nous dit que les vaccins
vont arriver en janvier février là moi
je fais partie des français qui sont
très perplexe pour paddy réticents à la
vaccination
encore une fois je suis content que le
prétendant public est dit que la
vaccination ne serait pas obligatoire
j'aurais trouvé ça complètement fou en
fait il ya neuf mois on ne savait pas
cracovie 19 exister neuf mois après on
nous sort un maxi
alors qu'on vous dit qu habituellement
pour sorti un maxi env entre 5 et 10 ans
ce vaccin il va arriver sur le marché en
janvier février
on n'en connaît pas les effets
secondaires or il ya toujours des effets
secondaires je parle pas d'effets
secondaires immédiat puisque tout vaccin
main celui de la grippe a des effets
secondaires médias un peu de fièvre de
courbatures et c'est pas cela dont je
parle je parle des effets secondaires je
vais te dire de moyen terme après huit
neuf dix mois un an
que se soient fait vacciner on n'en
connaît pas les effets de moi
personnellement je vous le dis
tranquillement deux que je suis assez
perplexe
plutôt très prudent de ce côté là je ne
ferai pas partie des premiers français
qui voudront se faire vacciner
[Musique]
nicolas sarkozy c'est un personnage qui
est clivant un don qu'il est en même
temps très complexe ses amis les plus
proches
ils y ont donné surnom c'est le parrain
je dis pas que c'est le papa nicolas
sarkozy mais ça veut dire que c'est un
chef c'est un capot c'est la lame d'un
patron après est ce que la justice
s'acharne sur lui je sais que nicolas
sarkozy quand il est aux responsabilités
avaient critiqué les juges alors
peut-être qui en retour de bâton et
peut-être du vrai mais tout donné
peut-être pas c'est moi j'ai eu affaire
à la justice que je sais que la justice
est un moment donné c'est aussi l'intimé
conviction d'un juge
c'est pas que le droit c'est pas que le
juridique c'est aussi l'image que le
juge peut avoir d'un prévenu de
quelqu'un qui est en face et parfois le
juge il a pas d'éléments matériels
mais son intime conviction fait qu'il a
décidé quelques uns des coupes avec ans
et sa wii tout faire c'est dupond
moretti qui l'a dit quand vous êtes pris
entre les mâchoires de la justice que
soient les riches pauvres innocents
coupables de qu'un moment donné vous y
passez donc de quoi sarkozy
je sais pas ce qui est vrai je sais pas
ce qu'il faut je ne me permettrais pas
je sais que la justice n est pas si
juste que ça moi je ne fais pas partie
de ceux qui appellent à la démission à
chaque fois qu'il ya un problème la
démission d'un ministre ça ne règle pas
les sujets aldama d'un c'est pas non
plus le diable en personne moi je suis
pas trop en phase avec sa manière d'être
mise l'intérieur je considère que miser
l'intérieur qui suit toute la journée
c'est un peu gênant quoi j'ai imaginé
qu'il y avait autre chose à faire penser
une vision de la police une doctrine une
nouvelle formation des recrutements à
l'image de la société française
d'ailleurs de que moi pour moi darmanin
il devrait être un peu plus silencieux
et travailler dans l'intérêt
effectivement de la police
ce que moi je je vis mal le fait qu'une
rupture parfois entre la police et une
frange de la population de quai il faut
réduire ce fossé
il faut pas le faire en jetant de
l'huile sur le feu ou ou en essayant de
de surfer de sur l'actualité il faut le
faire sereinement prenant du recul mais
à l'intérieur de la travailler
sereinement sérieusement dans l'ombre et
se doit surtout ne pas rester dans dans
les mots il doit être dans les arcs dans
les actes concrets au service du pays au
service de la police au service des
citoyens
[Musique]
le football c'est le reflet de la
société
s'il ya du racisme dans la société il y
en a dans le football à l'évidence
pourquoi il ya des gens qui ont des
idées nous avons deux candidats des
glaces donc comme partout dans la
société
y a pas que des êtres parfaits ni dans
les tribunes est mis sur le terrain
donc si on veut lutter vraiment contre
le racisme dans le football il faut que
les instances au plus haut niveau
n'attendent pas que les joueurs quittent
le terrain à chaque fois qu'ils aient
des cris de singe de qu'il faut
commander on prenne vraiment des
décisions de fortes qu'on frappe un
grand coup de queue d'abord c'est un peu
comme le hooliganisme en à lutter contre
le hooliganisme en angleterre moi j'ai
été footballeur professionnel ça a été
mon métier ma première vie donc c'est là
que j'ai appris l'école de la vie
j'étais avec des blancs des noirs des
que des gens d'origine maghrébine des
petits c'est pas le sujet le sujet c'est
le plaisir du sport c'est l'amour du
sport
je pense qu'on est on est parfois trop
laxiste face au phénomène de racisme on
n'est pas assez ferme on n'est pas assez
clair fond je suis républicain et la
république est liberté égalité
fraternité le monde
moi j'ai pas envie qu'on m'impose le
jour ont fait a fait donc le 31 c'est de
réveillon du jour de l'an certes mais si
j'ai pas le goût de sortir ou avoir des
aligne j'ai jamais fait la fête parce
qu'il fallait faire la fête
donc il a fait on peut la faire toute
l'année on peut la faire quand on est
enfant quand on envie quand les
conditions sont réunies
là en l'occurrence c'est un 31 assez
particulier le premier ministre annonce
et un couvre-feu qui sera effectif pour
le 31 moi je vais rester tranquille en
famille donc avec ma femme mes enfants
parce que je pense qu'il ne sortirait
pas ils ne sortiront pas et puis on voit
là on va profiter tranquillement de la
famille c'est des moments où il faut
profiter des siens parce que le reste de
l'année on est très occupé
[Musique]